what else we got up next we got Rachel
and Ranger from Buford some Ranger ah-ha
time for a chick huh oh it's a her name
is Ranger or the kids is I'm pretty sure
the kid
my son has a friend named Ranger what's
up and in what's up the oven it's Rachel
and Ranger from Beaufort South Carolina
I hear a bird in the back to King under
sting a fan I've done this in the BC
times before child and I just watched
Theo do it on the Graham picking up
hitchhikers what do you think praise God
dang oh so cute Monica don't want that
titty huh I want that bottle yeah we
give them the fig Lim have the real
thing no timeout that coca-cola either
get that tip of that soft white meat in
his mouth breast milk baby give that
fresh milk dude mommies let our
neighbors breastfeed us do I make sense
you know but you got that [ __ ] hit
you got that nature's reserve off that
lady you know that backup yeah they're
not oh you could drink all day dude milk
all whenever you want out it's milking
it milk everywhere milk here milk here
at it they're at it bro
oh she wants to know with hitchhikers I
like my life man I don't want to die
it's 2019 yeah also there's ubermann
dude i Hawaii I get a little different a
little different vibe but here in LA he
picking up hitchhiker Charles Manson was
a hitchhiker hard-ass yeah he was hard
passed dude the Manson Family I thought
they got around bro it's true
hitchhiking whoa oh yeah a lot of
hitchhike and I picked up a lot of
different hitchhikers over the years all
types to do one time this guy that
pulled a cold beer out of his [ __ ]
coat ice cold it wasn't nice yeah looks
pretty good Michelob it was I mean it
was a hot day and this man was out there
he pulled that ice cold
I've been Jesus bro it was cold as heck
and also this other record told me one
time he said that one time a guy picked
him up
who is in a high-speed chase from the
police gangster yeah just trying to help
the world and the guys like do what the
[ __ ] did you pick me up for you know
like I want to ride but I'm not like
fine I like and the guy said cuz I don't
want to die alone the police like the
next two hours and they ended up in the
cornfield lodge the car on a corner oh
the best friends for this day he I
didn't get any more information on him
out of that I picked up a family one
time took him to get gas for him back to
the car they didn't even say thank you
one time Oh grateful [ __ ] hurt your
feelings bro yeah what I said something
just still hurt my feelings a little
dude you remember when I was a kid I
should be scared of hitchhikers because
if you remember pee-wee Herman's big
adventure he picked up Large Marge
the Large Marge pick Large Marge picked
him up in the semi truck that's right
she's like you're all gonna die indeed
Large Marge send him or not Large Marge
was a demonic
driver was she a big lady or not not
that large
she looks a little short but thick Jerri
though and she not being like dad for 30
years yeah she's a ghost
alright so I was always scared of
hitchhikers because of that this is a
movie I remember that scene oh yeah yeah
yeah Chapelle didn't even have no candy
[Laughter]
he just had his thoughts and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
music - yeah oh yeah
little Beethoven huh now I hear what you
if you hit them in the livery start
singing [ __ ] blink-182 fan ever I
kick you in the leg you start singing
Green Day hitmen do you have the time in
the throat it's some 41
you name all these bands that I don't
even listen to yeah I did that's a
respect you slap his wrist he starts
singing train train is pretty good man
they fell off but they had what was
their main song I was a Jew pa'dar man
meet Virginia meet Virginia uh-huh
I can't wait to God just go meet her
dude could mean a [ __ ] yeah well it was
his friend's daughter that was the
problem
oh that's right across my friend Joe
meanest yeah yeah you like my dog sir
not like your dog sure you like it duty
bro Yeah right you should don't was that
Versace yeah dude you're one of those
Doberman reach readers bro you're
retreating from your [ __ ] original
stance I said I liked it bro
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]